ok grazie molto grazie a te per questo
invito
questa sera vi voglio parlare
del sistema museale dei musei civici di
venezia
secondo quello che definiscono a poco un
approccio poco sexy nel senso parliamo
di musei con i numeri e con i processi
parliamo di un sistema di gestione nuova
del
patrimonio museale pubblico quindi un
metodo gestionale che in italia in
europa trova comunque delle sfide enormi
quotidianamente nella programmazione
nella gestione e nella manutenzione
ho preparato questa sera alcune slide
giusto per guidarci attraverso
questo patrimonio visto sempre come
dicevo prima per il tramite dei numeri
dei processi gestionali quando parliamo
di musei civici di venezia parliamo di
un insieme organico di serie di
collezioni estremamente ampio
estremamente vario che raccoglie i
seguenti musei un patrimonio artistico e
culturale
vario
io amo sempre a definire un quatri monio
che va dalle tartarughe marine del museo
di storia naturale fino alle dame del
carpaccio del correr quindi un
patrimonio
affascinante ma anche di difficile
gestione
i musei che noi abbiamo nel nostro
network sono musei che ospitano
collezioni storiche
collezioni sulla storia di venezia ma
anche che hanno un approccio all'arte
moderna altre contemporanea in
particolare ca pesaro o palazzo fortuny
nel 2008 il comune di venezia decise di
esternalizzare una sorta di spin off
dell'azienda comunale ed area e
costituire una fondazione una fondazione
di diritto privato di fatto la normativa
dei primi anni 2000 fornisce in italia
la possibilità di
costituire una fondazione diritto
privato percorso per gestire un
patrimonio pubblico
in questo contesto il comune quindi crea
la fondazione musei civici di venezia
nel 2008 una fondazione detta di di
partecipazione dal secondo un approccio
la definizione giuridica
e dà a questa fondazione la
responsabilità della gestione diretta
delle sedi museali di cui vi ho parlato
prima vi ho fatto vedere la slide
precedente parliamo di un sistema molto
complesso che oltre ad ospitare
collezioni permanenti
realizza anche esposizioni temporanee
offre regolarmente i servizi al pubblico
per il tramite delle proprie biblioteche
e ogni anno in media
vede circa duemila visitatori
fra tutte le undici sedi
2 milioni
il comune aveva la necessità di
costituire una fondazione per due motivi
è stato in qualche modo anticipato
quella che era la sfida degli anni
successivi in materia di scarsità di
risorse pubbliche quindi scarsità di
trasferimenti pubblici questo un
problema che si vive a venezia ma come
si vive nel resto d'italia anche nel
resto d'europa di fatto sono finiti i
tempi in cui
con il patrimonio con trasferimenti
pubblici si riusciva a gestire il
patrimonio museale quindi lo strumento
della formazione di partecipazione viene
visto come il canale migliore per
provare una nuova sfida gestionale e di
valorizzazione delle sedi una sfida che
quindi parte dal pubblico con il comune
di venezia come socio fondatore e che
però si apre si deve aprire al privato
quindi dando la possibilità a soggetti
privati di entrare nella vita e nella
programmazione delle collezioni e delle
attività culturali e scientifiche del
patrimonio museale veneziano
la fondazione dei musei civici è una
fondazione non profit quindi non ha uno
scopo di lucro non è come una società
una spa i cui proventi ovviamente utili
vengono
suddivisi tra i soci tutto l'utile che
si genera viene reinvestito nel
patrimonio stesso per la conservazione
degli immobili per la conservazione la
manutenzione delle opere e per la
valorizzazione delle stesse
due parole sul modello organizzativo
della fondazione quando nasce nel 2008
di fatto esce dall amministrazione
pubblica con tutta un numero di
dipendenti anche si trova di fronte una
sfida grandissima o meglio passare dalle
procedure finanziarie amministrative e
gestionali tipica dell'ente pubblico e
costruirsi come azienda come una propria
contabilità dei propri processi
gestionali e pero si trova di fronte ad
un sistema doppiamente complesso perché
perché si posiziona nel modello multi
unit o meglio in un sistema museale dove
tutti i musei che qui sono rappresentati
dal museo a b e c l'aci ripresa due
volte ma dovrebbe esserci una diva
di fatto vengono serviti da un sistema
centrale per quanto riguarda ad esempio
l'elemento più importante che il
monitoraggio
e gli interventi di manutenzione
ordinaria straordinaria che la
fondazione realizza in strettissima
sinergia con l'amministrazione comunale
ma anche tutta la parte di monitoraggio
dei flussi di visitatori di servizi ai
visitatori
quindi diversamente diciamo da dei
modelli che potenzialmente hanno un
livello di complessità minore
potenzialmente ovviamente si posiziona
nella slide che voi vedete lì a destra
un elemento importante da segnalare che
il sistema museale civico di venezia non
oggi
fin dalla sua nascita non ha
alcun trasferimento pubblico è un caso
unico in italia e a quanto ci risulta
anche quanto risulta ministero dei beni
culturali in europa di gestione di un
patrimonio museale pubblico che vive
senza trasferimenti pubblici di alcun
genere dal ministero dalla regione o
dalla provincia dal comune di fatto vive
con la bigliettazione
l'attività di fund raising quindi wrap
di
interazione con potenziali sponsor e con
dei servizi aggiuntivi che a partire
2008 la fondazione sta man mano
implementando e sviluppando siano questi
servizi ai visitatori
quindi da itinerari nuovi di visita
rispetto alle sedi kospi che gestiamo a
lo sviluppo più marcato nei servizi di
ristorazione o di book shop o
tipicamente il merchandising per realtà
private o che in altre parti d'europa e
del mondo è una cosa consolidata da
decenni di fatto nel sistema italiano
pubblico è comunque una cosa che parte
solamente recentemente sulla quale anche
la fondazione cerca di
inserirsi chiaramente con un obiettivo
diversificare le fonti d'entrata quindi
abbassare il livello di rischio di
dipendenza da dall'unica dipendenza
della bigliettazione quindi creare degli
introiti che abbiano origini diverse
ci siamo dati degli obiettivi
dicevo nasce nel settembre 2008 diventa
operativa di sempre 2008 viene
predisposto un business plan a tre anni
con degli obiettivi
ovviamente l'incremento dei ricavi
lavorando sulle leve di marketing alcune
delle quali menzionavo prima
un obbligo un dovere
ma anche un diritto quello della
conservazione del patrimonio dicevo
prima alla grande sfida della
manutenzione degli immobili
venezia per la sua particolarità ha dei
costi incredibili oggi questo viene
affrontato sinergicamente in stretta
collaborazione con il comune anche dal
punto di vista finanziario ma sempre
meno attendere per i motivi di cui
dicevo prima la scarsità di risorse
pubbliche di trasferimenti
l'ottimizzazione delle risorse cosa
significa
abbiamo organizzato un appalto molto
importante per la gestione servizi
museali quindi intendo la biglietteria
la guardiania delle sale la polizia la
security notturna un appalto con delle
modalità che rispetto ai 10 anni
precedenti hanno i soli dieci mesi del
2010 dato alle casse della fondazione a
900 mila euro in più netti un sistema
sostanzialmente che prevede delle fasce
di suddivisione degli introiti con il
gestore dei servizi museali delle fasce
che provano a scalare e quindi
garantiscono al gestore comunque una
solida base per poter erogare i servizi
ma che alla fondazione quindi
all'amministrazione comunale e quindi
alla città con maggiori ricavi danno
anche maggiori risorse
risparmio energetico un obbligo perché
anche qui come dicevo prima
mancando dei trasferimenti e quindi
dovendosi insegnare dal lato dei ricavi
sia dal lato del contenimento dei costi
quello del risparmio energetico diventa
un elemento fondamentale
quindi ci siamo mossi in due direzioni
una una forte rinegoziazione delle
forniture di energia e di altri servizi
e dall'altra un monitoraggio molto
dettagliato di quelli che sono
l'utilizzo degli spazi e degli impianti
faccio un esempio su tutti la
sostituzione dei corpi illuminanti di
tutte le sedi museali ci sono diversi
migliaia i corpi illuminanti nelle sedi
museali con dei costi estremamente
elevati sia di
sostituzione che di manutenzione e in
questo senso ci stiamo muovendo in
un'ottica di risparmio e anche di
contenimento dei costi di manutenzione
ultimo ma certamente non meno importante
un occhio di particolare riguardo a
quella che si definisce alla
soddisfazione del cliente viene
ovviamente un l'introduzione di un
sistema di qualità sulle di valutazione
su quelli che sono i giudizi del cliente
rispetto ai servizi che noi eroghiamo e
anche qui detto in altre realtà in altre
parti del mondo
io sto pensando agli interlocutori di
ted che sono soliti partecipare e
visitare i musei tutto il mondo è una
cosa normale ma che diciamo per un
sistema museale pubblico parlo per
l'italia comunque pur essendo importante
non è mai stato probabilmente tra le top
priority quindi per noi questo diventa
un elemento importante quindi viene
monitorata regolarmente quella che è la
soddisfazione del cliente cercando di
adattare il servizio erogato
giusto qualche numero quando siamo
partiti
dicevo prima abbiamo fatto un business
plan a tre anni ci siamo detti perché
l'azienda potesse rimanere in piedi e
con i costi dell'epoca dobbiamo
immaginare di avere un 6 per cento di
abilitazione ai servizi aggiuntivi noi a
oggi quindi dopo due anni e mezzo su due
anni e mezzo nonostante la grossa crisi
2009 che ha colpito anche noi ronnie due
anni e mezzo ho avuto un incremento dell
11,7 per cento dei ricavi la
bigliettazione
del 16,4
dei servizi aggiuntivi quindi
ristorazione book shop
guide ad hoc
abbiamo avuto un aumento dei visitatori
che potete vedere dalla slide abbastanza
significativo che chiaramente
penalizzato dal 2009 nel quale punto il
calo è stato notevole ma che è stato
rilanciato dal 2010 e nei primi mesi del
abbiamo lavorato sull'apertura di nuovi
spazi ora tutto questo per dire che come
un modello gestionale
ha garantito sta garantendo
all'amministrazione comunale quindi al
alla gestione pubblica della cosa
certamente un approccio più flessibile
più immediato
e allo stesso tempo controllato e
monitorato dall'ente pubblico il quale
alla fine comunque giustamente richiede
un sistema di reporting regolare
sull'attività che viene fatta sui
bilanci che avevano approvati sulla
programmazione artistica scientifica che
viene proposta dal consiglio di
amministrazione
io vorrei concludere il mio intervento
anche qualche minuto prima della fine
sostanzialmente evidenziando due cose
di fatto con la costituzione della
fondazione
l'amministrazione comunale quindi l'ente
pubblico ha
dato in gestione il sistema molto
complesso che creava delle problematiche
anche interne all'amministrazione
comunale proprio per la particolarità
della vita museale che è molto molto
diversa da quella che che può essere le
erogazioni in servizio di anagrafe
piuttosto che di controllo ambientale
piuttosto che
di cerimonia il pubblico e al tempo
stesso però come dicevo prima si è
garantita un sistema di controllo sulla
stessa
noi crediamo che il sistema fondazione
di partecipazione
applicato al sistema museale pubblico
almeno sulla base della nostra
esperienza possa essere vincente per due
motivi principali il primo perché
comunque garantisce anche soprattutto
nella gestione di un network i musei la
sopravvivenza ma non solo anche la
stessa
valorizzazione di quei musei che invece
da soli non potrebbero farcela
quindi intervenendo centralmente sulla
gestione dei servizi comuni abbassando i
costi facendo dell'economia di scala si
possono sostenere sia in j di appeal e
di richiamo come nel nostro caso ad
esempio palazzo ducale che allunga del
museo che ha
più importante ma allo stesso tempo dar
vita a mantenere e sviluppare sui
sistemi quei musei minori che invece
diversamente da soli non ce la farebbero
ma che invece da un punto di vista
culturale
da un punto di vista scientifico dal
punto di vista della collettività è
importante continuino a vivere ea
crescere e quindi ad arricchirsi e
secondo crediamo che questo sistema di
fondazione di partecipazione e di costi
di gestione a rete di musei possa anche
essere da stimolo per un partenariato
pubblico pubblico ad esempio fondazione
di venezia unico socio comune di venezia
ma a venezia come in altre realtà
esistono ovviamente sistemi museali la
gestione pure le pubblici gestiti dal
livello regionale piuttosto che
nazionale quindi questo potrebbe essere
uno strumento in termini di management
da seguire da utilizzare e poi
certamente pubblico privato unico
privato che in quota parte noi già
abbiamo avviato in questi due anni e sul
quale così come
i sistemi privati i sistemi museali
privati già fanno da sempre può
rappresentare anche per la gestione
pubblica un modello organizzativo nuovo
e vincente
ho detto l'inserimento evento che era
poco sexy parlando di arte prospero gli
abbia dato l'idea di quella che è un
patrimonio molto molto importante ma
certamente di non facilissima gestione
grazie molto
grazie a mattia netti